chris sims unveiled his quarterback
rankings in advance of the 2020 draft
earlier this week tuatanga vialoa the
surprise at number four one spot ahead
of him jordan love from utah state we
talked yesterday about why tonga viloa
is four let's focus on why jordan love
is three what do you see in him that
makes you think he's one of the best
guys available this year chris well all
right so the first thing that has to you
have to talk about is and this is the
big thing is why in 2018 was he so much
better than he was in 2019 well
just like anything i mean his coach left
him to go become the texas tech head
coach their offense fell off greatly in
2019 so the film always isn't as smooth
and it's nice and again i'm going to use
my jared stidham com uh comparison you
know jared stidham if he left a year
early he's going to be a first round
pick goes to all you know he stays in
school one more year our auburn's team
falls apart and all of a sudden we blame
jared stidham for the fact that the
right guard can't catch or nobody can
get open down the field and that's just
not fair jordan loves physical ability
it's superstar ability mike it's a
special arm it really is and a special
alarm that you know i understand people
make comparisons and go oh you can do
patrick mahomes type things i'm going to
say whoa let's pump the brakes slow down
but i understand what they're saying
mike he's a guy that you know as i watch
the film more and more makes a lot of
high level nfl type throws and can throw
it with ease people in his face sidearm
30 yard laser down the right sideline
back shoulder bam on the money you know
deep out routes throws deep down the
field he's got special gifts special arm
and you know i think he sees the feel
well am i a little concerned that he
threw a lot of interceptions last last
year yeah okay but as i looked all at
most of the interceptions some are on
him but i think the majority of them go
on the utah state offense listen there's
just too many plays where i sit there
and go nobody's open or this is the same
four plays i've seen over and over and
we're in the third quarter and this is
the seventh time they've run this play
so it affected his play and then of
course utah state not being very good he
had to play aggressive at times if they
wanted to win football games and that
with the lack of imagination on offense
leads to some you know
not great looking film but it's not
jordan love that's where i want people
to start realizing that listen i'm not
going to give tua tango viola an a-plus
grade when i see him throw a swing route
to the back two yards behind the line of
scrimmage and he runs 70 yards down the
field because they designed some great
play and go oh my gosh he's the only
quarterback in football that could do
that no jordan love could have done that
too you know and that's where i think
people get lost in this at times it's
about projecting to the nfl love has
size athleticism can throw the ball in
the pocket with people around them can
deliver it from all diff different
awkward angles has a big time arm mic
and has a great hand to just flick the
ball too so i really see a lot of
potential for this kid and i think a lot
of the issues this year were the team
and the offense and not jordan love and
people need to stop falling into those
traps
it's one thing to put him at number
three on your list of quarterbacks it's
another thing to find a spot for him
in round one
where do you think he fits and this gets
complicated because you start comparing
him with other guys at other positions
but what's a good spot for him to come
off the board once they start calling
the names
yeah well you know listen i mean miami
dolphins they wanted to get out of the
number five spot and trade down a little
bit and they felt like jordan love might
be there at 10 or 12 and he's the guy
they like hey that's a possibility you
know uh that
any of the quarterback needy teams if
they don't feel like taking one in the
top three or five or anything like that
to me jordan love is a first round
quarterback he is he has first round
traits he's extremely talented and you
know i think he's gonna fit in any type
of offense mike he can throw on the run
he can throw the ball deep you know he
really has it all to me and i think
that's the thing that jumps out to me i
and i know listen people keep pushing me
on this well two or two or two it i get
it but i watch two of film and i don't
see any nfl throws in fact the throws
when i want to go oh this is going to be
an nfl throw there's people around him
he doesn't complete them and i don't
want to meet mata there but i'm just
trying to keep it real to the people out
there who are going how could you have
jordan love in front of dua we'll be
back at pft right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports